what's up guys
it's lunch money and we're in a rush so
today you're going to get the shortened
version
block five is the sponsor go get a block
by account wifi.com
you can earn up to 8.6 interest you can
buy and sell assets on a crypto exchange
or you can deposit crypto take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral go to block fight.com
pomp i'm not kidding we're gonna do this
in eight minutes go
uh michael saylor of microstrategy has
purchased an additional 262 bitcoins for
15 million dollars in cash
michael saylor is the savage michael
sailor has conviction and michael saylor
will not stop go michael saylor go
michael sailor go michael
go michael go michael go michael
japanese tech giant rakuten
to raise 2.2 billion dollars by issuing
new shares
to walmart 10 cent and japan post
what the hell is what the hell is rocket
doing snap your fingers 2 billion
falls from the sky that only happens in
bull markets but
again what do i know the macro
environment is getting
real crazy real frothy but there's
another 1.9 trillion on the
way all right sequoia capital is
throwing
millions of dollars at this company
called gather which is a virtual hq
platform and literally it's going to be
creating virtual worlds this is the
future guys
i mean honestly i kind of feel like i
should have invested in this company it
sounds amazing i would love to have a
virtual world that all of us could go
into the
virtual lunch money headquarters wow
okay uh so people yesterday sold
his piece for 69 million dollars he is
now
a rich man and people are explaining
what you get
right if you uh bought this what do you
get so the buyer of his everyday's piece
gets
essentially a long string of numbers and
letters and a massive high resolution
jpeg
go people go people go people go people
i told you i was going to go for 50
million
anyway no you're you get the nft it's
amazing
this is smart this is the sign of what's
to come there will be somebody who sells
one for more than 69 million dollars i'm
calling it now book it keep the receipts
all right netflix is running a test
that's cracking down on password sharing
some customers are getting a message on
their screens prompting them to sign up
for their own account if they aren't
watching with the subscriber
netflix has historically ignored the
password sharing but uh
now it's it's paying attention do we
think that's because they're like
all right enough is enough we're big
enough let's get some more revenue here
uh netflix you ain't catching me you
don't know who's got the password i
might be in two places at once it's
called the inception you ain't gonna
find me
go ahead okay all right family plan last
lunch money time
ask lm in the comments below
today we have a question from uh
sunit batea nfts and crypto are blowing
up what are the next use cases
you see for crypto in 2021 bitcoin
that's what i see
bitcoin is going to continue to be
adopted on a global scale and it's going
to be awesome but i also think that
decentralized applications on top of
bitcoin you guys may not think that
that's going to be a big deal but i'm
telling you
decentralized applications on top of
bitcoin they're here
more of them are coming i'm seeing the
people building them it's going to be a
big deal
we'll see we have some more time all
right no let's go
gabrielle it's moist time voice counter
gabriella commented
and she said moist hey hey buddy we got
a little bit of a age difference which
she's not that concerned about but she
says however it seems like you don't
appreciate people pointing out the
difference in your socks
i'm very detail oriented i studied
product design and can notice little
things like that
a lot ah you're talking my language
gabriella
that's not so much the problem either
the problem is that i tend to wear
different socks on purpose
i'm more on the shy side and wearing
different socks increases my chances to
interact with people
without having to start the conversation
myself that said i had a ghost visiting
a ghost living in my house too her name
was marta and she liked to turn the
lights on and off she wasn't harmful
either but she's gone now
anyway she says i don't know if this
sparks any curiosity on your side moist
but i'll always be open to meeting
intelligent and interesting people
although i don't think we live in the
same country you can find me on twitter
with my youtube name you never know who
will become your next
insert something partner
here what do we think what do we
think moist and gabriella might take
away from all of this is gabriella
killed a ghost
no wait what was she because she had a
ghost and it's not there anymore so i
don't know where
i don't know what happened but it sounds
like gabriella killed a ghost
she's a ghost killer
all right one voice counter day 22.
uh he said this is a trick question the
peanut butter goes on one side of the
bread the jam on the other
and then they are merged together the
peanut butter is put on first because
it's better to get
a little bit of peanut butter in the jam
jar than the other way around i'm
telling you moist and i are the same
people
the guy gets it moist great answer it
was such a good answer
that i don't have a question for you for
the weekend instead what i want you to
do is i want you to post a question for
paulina and i
in the comments all right guys that's it
for lunch money gabriella moist
we're gonna create sogginess [ __ ]
get out done cuts see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polina
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to 8.6 interest on an
interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends